cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com Let's jump to the story
about the um the dystopian nightmare
that we're about to embrace and it's
probably mean to say I shouldn't say
that Nora link first in human clinical
trials is open for Recruitment and I
want to soften this a little bit
what's going to happen right now is that
people who are paralyzed who are deaf
who can't see are going to get a chance
to have their lives back or you know if
some people I don't want to imply that
some people are are you know miserable
or happy where some people are totally
fine and happy and they've adapted and
they're living good lives but some
people may be thinking this is my chance
to maybe walk again this is why
neurolink is awesome the scary thing is
Nora link is the is the door
that once you open it up The Path out
leads to people isolating themselves in
pods where they have feeding tubes full
of pumping bug slime into their bellies
while they live in the matrix by choice
but this is the the latest big news Elon
Musk tweeted about it saying
the first human patient will soon
receive a neuralink device this
ultimately has the potential to restore
full body movement in the long term
norling hopes to play a role in AI risk
civilization risk reduction by improving
human to Ai and human to human bandwidth
by several orders of magnitude imagine
if Stephen Hawking had had this
um I also want to just point out what
he's saying about AI risk civilization
risk reduction
he's saying that if humans integrate
with the AI it won't destroy us
he's talking about integrating human
brains with other human brains
you know I think Elon does great work
and I think it's important that you know
to a certain degree like we certainly
want to cure people who are paralyzed
with medical technology
but I gotta say man
it's going to get scary you guys ready
to plug your brain into the Matrix yeah
absolutely not no that's it's like yeah
I like I like what Elon Musk is doing
with Twitter I'm not about to let him
put a computer in my head I mean that
that's ridiculous and you know the other
aspect of this is that the first people
to take advantage of this will be like
the elite the people in the um you know
in take advantage of it in a way that is
more than just like helping a paralyzed
person walk which you know obviously
that's the way that they're going to
introduce it because who who would
disagree with that but you know it was
way beyond that when neurolink is
capable of in terms of like increasing
your IQ or your uh all sorts of stuff
and so you know you're going to have a
sort of feedback loop where the people
in the highest positions of power in the
society get it first and that just
solidifies their position as they uh you
know continue to uh
they say those who have quadriplegia due
to cervical spine spinal cord injury or
ALS may qualify so for now I mean we're
not talking about plugging people's
brains into the Matrix neural link is
actually going to be saving lives and
and curing ailments and I can respect
that I know a lot of people are saying
don't rag on neurolink because it's
going to provide uh you know treatment
for a lot of people and that's really
really cool
uh my fear is just that if we go to the
ever get to the point where we can read
write into a person's brain experiences
yeah no one's going to live in the real
world anymore well the other aspect is
you know the the gray reset the the
world economic form right you'll own
nothing you'll have no privacy but
you'll be happy I mean that that dates
back to the you know 1960s when you had
Aldous Huxley saying basically they'll
put you in a position where you ought
not be happy but you'll be made happy
when they literally are releasing
dopamine so you're sitting there on like
a and you know this is like the 1960s
version but you're sitting there on an
assembly line you should be like
miserable like God this is awful but
instead you're like this is the best
thing I've ever this is the most fun
I've ever had is putting together these
car parts because they're literally
activating the pleasure Center of your
brain as you're doing this do you guys
uh you guys know what uh you know you
know the story of the monkey's paw right
yes the monkey spot it gives you three
wishes but it twists your wishes into
awful ways and or or there's just like
Needful Things this Trope of be careful
what you wish for has been around for a
long time I remember uh when I was
little I can't remember what what movie
we were watching I was watching with my
family and it's like somebody gets a
monkey's paw or whatever and then
they're like I wish for a million
dollars and then all of a sudden like
the person's wife walks out to pick up a
newspaper and gets hit by a car killing
her instantly and then you know the guy
in the car is like oh no I'll give you a
million dollars settlement or whatever
like he or an insurance pay out they're
like you're being awarded a million
dollars so that the wish is twisted my
dad was always like you know you know
how you beat the monkey's paw you wish
for happiness
wish that you were happy and what could
it do to twist it and I was like
it'll put you in a mental institution in
a straight jacket Bang Your Head on the
wall and goes but you're happy
and I'm like that's an interesting way
of viewing happiness is that it's
technically the truth yeah there's a uh
it's the happiness they'll give you
there's a Chuck palahnik uh short story
that's kind of like that where it's this
phenomenon where uh all these kids in
high school realize that if you like
electrocute yourself you basically like
lobotomize yourself and so it's like a
trend of kids like electrocuting
themselves and lobotomizing themselves
because they'd rather be happy and
mentally incapacitated than have to deal
with the stresses of uh of real life yo
people are going to be like in the real
world I work at uh uh you know I work a
menial job but when I go home to my pod
and plug in man I host this big nightly
podcast with millions of followers it's
really great you know yeah to a Morning
Show yeah and I mean that and that again
you know this is what the the people
that are whether we like it or not
planning our future right the global
government that already exists and is in
operation right now they you know come
out and say they're like you know once
we have all these robotics people are
going to be useless so we have to find
something for them to do we have to find
something to occupy their time which is
exactly that it's put you in a pod
connect you to the neuro link and
suddenly you're happy and and playing
video games but you guys you guys
wouldn't want to play video games in the
neuraling no I mean do you play video
games yeah what's your favorite game
Baldur's Gate you're playing Baldur's
Gate right now I'm not playing the third
one you're not playing third no wait
what are you talking about how you
playing Ballers game you're not playing
the new one and I just played the one
from 1995. well it's a really great game
you wouldn't want to actually be able to
experience being in the world of
Baldur's Gate and throwing Fireballs at
dragons and uh you may I I I look people
not that means I'm putting a USB port in
the back of my head I think it'll be
Wireless
well either way no I think but I mean
that is the danger I mean we're already
even with the level of Technology we
have now we're already experiencing this
where like so many even like my friends
like they get their fulfillment in the
facsimile of Success Through video games
have you ever heard the phrase fully
automated luxury communism that is the
future that a lot of people want and
that is the future that a plugged in
neuralink pod offers you don't have to
do anything if you're laying in the pot
it's fully automated your serotonin and
dopamine centers are stimulated for you
so you are you own nothing and you're
happy and you literally just exist in
the pot here's a go on a Samuel Rucker
with a super chat saying don't forget
that neurolink can be used as an
interface for a super soldier super suit
like Iron Man that was literally the
second to musk tweeted about uh what's
called then this the next tweet that he
had it was a little clip from Star Wars
with Luke Skywalker's hand but but the
you know you wonder how it is that Tony
Stark Pilots the Iron Man suit well it's
going to be human it's gonna be what
computer brain interface but I I do
think the moment everybody says no
everybody says they won't do it
everybody said they won't get a cell
phones everybody's got a cell phone and
everyone's like I don't want a
government tracking device in my pocket
now I have three only old people will
say no only people our age and older oh
I think a lot of people want this like I
mean we look at it through a critical
lens but I think that actually there's a
significant portion of Americans who
will Who want to be crazy and they want
to immediately Reach This Nirvana that
is being sold to it
people will sell
experiences yeah so like you're you're a
chef so what you do is
what you have to do is plug in the
neural link cook the fancy meal
film it and then eat it and it records
what your brain is saying as you're
eating this food and then that
experience of eating this delicious meal
can be then sent to the game world where
it now appears on the menu like someone
has to record the brain patterns to give
to another person before it can you
can't just go into this video game this
neuralink world and be like I want a
filet mignon someone's got to record
what a brain experiences what signals
are sent when someone is eating a
delicious medium rare filet mignon so
basically this is a way to become vegan
without being vegan right oh I mean dude
you're gonna eat the bugs come on yeah
you're gonna you're gonna go in your pod
and you're gonna plug the feeding tube
into your neck yeah exactly and then
you're going to Zonk out and then you're
gonna live for like I don't there's the
idea that they could do
um make make you exp like time dilation
in the indoor length like speed things
up so that in the real world it's you
know eight hours of sleep but you live
for 80 years or something like that I
don't know about that that may or may
not be true but you're gonna plug in
you're gonna get home from work or
whatever you're gonna be like finally
and go back to being president again
plug in your feeding tube and then wake
up as the president oh my God basically
you know what's funny this is a
rudimentary like like San Francisco this
is San Francisco right where everybody's
being given drugs and they're laying on
the streets and they don't have jobs but
now we're actually going to turn it into
something a lot more digital and and
effective
it's a scary thing I think the the big
hurdle for neuralink in terms of
commercial ubiquity will be it has to be
Wireless
like there's already the problem of
human rejection
so there are people who will cut open
their fingers and put neodymium magnets
in their fingers and then sew it shut
and this gives you uh I think it's some
people I think it's called Electro
perception or perhaps Electro sense and
the magnet inside your finger reacts to
electromagnetic fields giving you the
ability to feel EMF waves that's crazy
it gives you an additional sense I think
it's funny that people say we have five
senses we actually have substantially
more than five senses but you know
whatever you it's like you know what do
they say touch smell C and and hear
whatever and and taste but you also have
balance you also have temperature
there's a bunch of other ones and uh but
anyway
if you want to feel electromagnetic
fields you they they're the people who
do this so you know I don't recommend it
but the body rejects it they take a
magnet they code it in some polymer
stick it in your finger sew it shut but
slowly over time your body pushes it out
and then eventually it breaks and just
rips out of your finger
if we're going to do a neural link how
do you stop the body from rejecting it I
think what they're doing right now with
norlink and the stuff that I've seen is
they're very very thin copper wires that
just rest on the nerve connections
something like that
the big challenge for neural link going
commercial and ubiquitous is going to be
no one's going to want to get surgery
I mean maybe if it's like a tattoo if
they're like look we take this thing and
we go boom boom boom boom boom and we
put these these uh you know copper wires
in this and super easy and we can do it
it takes 15 minutes maybe people would
do it as long as they're drilling
quarter-sized holes into your skull
people are going to have a little bit of
ick factor and they're going to be a
little up apprehensive about that but
but people are already getting the chips
in their hands I mean you know the the
skin is not it's been like a decade yeah
yeah it's been a while there will be
people that are going to go ahead and
say we'll do it I'll do it right now
there will be people that'll that'll
definitely do that there's without a
question well they're already biohacking
and stuff standing in line for the orb
thing right uh yeah people people are
going to be into this so absolutely so I
I mean I guess it's just it is like
literally just like a spiritual uh thing
where you have to like reject the the
falsehood even if it's Pleasant even if
it feels good even if uh it seems like a
a easier experience than real life you
have to recognize that it's not real uh
and and rejected on that uh ground alone
thanks for watching in this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time